welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the loki's season 2 trailer was
shown at d23 and i was fortunate to see
it and while i left my bruce wayne body
cam contacts at home i did immediately
plug my brain into a server to download
as much of this imagery as i could and i
can tell you season 2 looks insane
deeply intertwined with the multiverse
saga to set up kang between quantomania
and avengers kang dynasty and following
up that cliffhanger season 1 finale in a
way that i did not expect so until this
trailer officially drops online here is
a fairly comprehensive breakdown of
everything that we learned from it the
footage opens with the tva elevator
doors opening with the sound of a bell
similar to how the trailer for season 1
opened
loki wanders the offices of the tva but
this tva is different it's dark vacant
nightmarish it's not even the tva that
loki was left in in the season 1 finale
because at least that had mobius and b15
and a few other chrono monitors and
hunters running around but here in this
one loki is completely alone the music
is incredible sounding like the work of
natalie holt who composed the first
season and here clearly evoking a
child's wind-up music box just three
staccato notes with the clockwork
ticking underneath it did
it sounds exactly like that so loki
calls out hello and then he tells
someone this is going to sound strange
i've been pulled through time i saw
terrible awful things this voiceover
plays over shots of loki glitching as he
walks through the dark and tva may have
seen some people online describe this as
the glitching of vanellope and wreck-it
ralph but that's just a go-to reference
for all disney nerds who went to d23
really the glitch is more like what it
looked like in loki season one whenever
loki or someone else tried to escape and
then they were suddenly rewound with a
temp pad so someone is now screwing with
loki using a temp pad and i think that
someone is kang not he remains but kang
the new kang variant who took over from
he remains and stole the he remains
corpse's master tim pad from the citadel
i actually theorized that that original
temp pad might be the thing that was
stolen from kang that kang now wants
scott lang to steal back for him in the
quantum mania footage loki tells us that
he's been pulled through time and saw
terrible awful things which is new
because that had not happened to him
when he arrived in the rebooted tva in
the season 1 finale and loki says it'll
sound strange which has got to be at
least a wink from the writers to us
referencing doctor strange in avengers
infinity war who pulled himself through
time using the time stone to look at 14
605 futures and was horrified by what he
saw sounds like this is what has now
happened to loki since he arrived in
this new tba the kang who lords over it
has used a temp pad to pull him forward
in time and show him all the horrifying
things that kang plans to do to the mcu
loki goes on to describe this saying
this is about everything there is
nothing to stand between this world and
utter destruction war is on its way so
why would kang tell his war plan to loki
i mean why does any bond villain tell
his hero the plans ahead of time is kang
doing this just to screw with loki or is
loki knowing the madness to come part of
kang's plan like the oracle of delphi
telling oedipus his fate kang could have
cursed loki with knowledge of the future
in order to bring kang's enemies
together in a specific self-fulfilling
prophecy making them easier to pick off
in kang dynasty and in secret wars
remember thanos told iron man we were
both cursed with knowledge knowledge of
the future is a kind of curse because it
forces you to accidentally walk down
that path in this footage we see loki
using a tv8 time stick to prune away a
mural showing the time keepers to reveal
multiple giant golden faces of kang
behind that mural each of them roughly
the size of the timekeeper paces that we
saw in the courtroom so i don't know if
this would be the same tva that loki
ended season one inside of because that
tva had already replaced all the
iconography of the timekeepers with kang
stuff and there would be no reason to
hide any kang iconography with the
facade of timekeepers here so this must
be either the original tva that loki
departed or a third tva that loki has
now traveled to which would be why this
now nightmarish one is so empty probably
the biggest announcement for the loki
panel is that kihui kwan is joining the
season 2 cast kwon just made a glorious
comeback and everything everywhere all
at once after his iconic roles as a
child actor in goonies and temple of
doom this trailer footage reveals he is
playing a kind of record keeper or
archivist who floats down through a
vault location to meet loki at a help
desk the whole moment feels like
something out of terry gilliam's brazil
then casey the tva clerk played by
eugene cardero will return in season two
because the new shot shows him panicked
crawling through a dark cramped space
like under the floorboards or an event
we also see a shot of sylvie lounging on
a sofa listening to vinyl records we do
know that characters will travel to
london in the 1970s we also saw a shot
of silvie wearing a 1970s mcdonald's
uniform and set imagery so that can be
connected to that but various new parts
of the tva are shown including a bright
room filled with natural light pouring
in from the outside with rounded
archways overhead we're just gonna have
to wait for the trailer to officially
drop online for me to break it down
properly but there is a shot of a
monster claw grabbing at the door of the
tva and this actually could tell us what
is going on and why the tva is so empty
so nightmarish like something out of a
horror movie because i broke down the
trailer for werewolf by night and that
footage includes some armored guards who
do kind of look like tva hunters i guess
their helmets aren't exactly the same
and their prods electrocute rather than
prune but remember mobius did mention a
nightmare department in loki episode 1.
this place is a nightmare that's another
department now that department i'll help
you burn down
in episode 4 double down on the tva
having dealt with supernatural threats
like vampires you know we brought in
cree
titans vampires why is it the two orphan
demigods are such a pain in the ass so
who knows werewolf by night could be
taking place in the tva's nightmare
department a department where
supernatural elements prune from the
timeline all live and are stored but now
with all the changes that have happened
to the tva from loki's season one that
department has gotten destabilized and
the monsters have broken loose like
something out of cabin in the woods and
that could result in this creepy
nightmarish tva that loki is now
glitching through now on another shot
loki and mobius are wearing vintage
tuxedos and mobius says a little over
the top don't you think i thought it was
sportone and we also see that there are
multiple variants of tom hiddleston loki
in this conversation and the trailer
ends with loki and mobius together
chatting and loki says i don't want you
to think i'm the bad guy in all this
mobius says who says you were iron man
captain america hulk black widow hawkeye
phil coulson thanos nick fury my father
my brother miss minutes you moby's just
drugs and conceits
it's always great to hear phil coulson's
name in the mcu because we've got to
show this man more respect but it's
interesting that loki says thanos called
him the bad guy at some point because
this loki departed from the sacred
timeline in 2012 in the battle of new
york in the first avengers film and
while this loki watched footage of his
future timeline into that future we
never really saw thanos calling loki a
villain so this must be a hint at
whatever thanos told loki when he first
sent him to conquer irv off-screen loki
also mentions miss minutes who in the
citadel offered him a chance to kind of
restore his place in the timeline
bringing her up here reminds us that she
is an active player in this world with a
role to play in season two is she the
thing that kang lost that scott lang
must steal back in quanah mania and what
exactly is miss minutes is she an ai
holo projection is she a sentient cosmic
being of some kind is she time itself
captured in this cute form let me know
your thoughts down below and follow me
on tik tok instagram and twitter avos
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you